bonjour lit la fin vous suivez ces
points évidemment du premier ministre
que faut-il retenir de ces deux
déclarations aujourd'hui mais alors
magali le premier ministre a déclaré que
non et sont qu'au début de cette vague
épidémique et il a averti que la
situation sanitaire ne risquait pas de
s'améliorer rapidement c'est pour ça
qu'il a été décidé de prolonger la
période de confinement jusqu'au 15 avril
sur conseils sur recommandation d'un
conseil scientifique propose de
l'écouter le renouvellement de la
période de confinement pour deux
semaines supplémentaires à compter de
mardi prochain soit jusqu'au mercredi 15
avril les mêmes règles que celles
actuellement en vigueur continueront à
s'appliquer cette période pourra
évidemment être prolongée si la
situation sanitaire l'exigé
si et seulement si la situation
sanitaire l'exigent vous savez que le
conseil scientifique qui éclairent les
décisions du gouvernement évalue à au
moins six semaines au global la période
totale de confinement il est encore trop
tôt pour le savoir avec certitude c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'annonce eux
cette décision et vous l'avez dit magali
la vague du virus ce déferle sur la
france
on a dépassé la barre des 1600 morts et
d'ailleurs on a compté une adolescente
ans qui est décédée une adolescente de
16 ans qui est décédée qui est devenu la
victime la plus jeune que l'hexagone est
connu merci la fois pour toutes ces
précisions lit la faam ouzou en direct
de la place beauvau dans le centre de
paris pas très loin de l'elysée